Hi everyone, in this lesson we're going to go and take a look at ways to organize your materials in the material graph
and how to keep things nice and clean as well as later we're going to look at creating an apparent material and an instance material.
So let's go and dive in and get started.
One way that you can get organized when working with your materials and how to get things in the right spot
to prevent over trafficking your noodles basically your strings crossing each other and being all over the place.
Don't cross the streams as they say in Ghostbusters.
You can use add named reroute declaration nodes as well as add a reroute node.
And let me show you how to do that as well as look at some comments that you can actually put into your scene as you're working with your material nodes.
So in real say I have this group of nodes that I've built and we're going to build these later on in another class.
We're primarily going to be focusing on these when we do build them out later.
But I'm going to pick on these guys for a second because they're a group of nodes that have an ends to a means or I should say a particular node output that we want to convey.
Now instead of pulling all the strings to all these different areas we can actually make it go to one particular node and that one particular node can then rest and sit in front of each one of these.
And it's basically naming and rerouting them so you don't have a lot of wires everywhere.
You can easily do so by right clicking and in here you can type in named reroute declaration node and we can say and call this one UVs.
This UV node can now sit here and I can punch everything into here and then from here I can actually call up the one we made it'll show it right here with Unreal.
And I'm just simply left clicking to get this or right clicking I should say to get this to come up and then we're going to click on the name to reroute and click on UVs.
And then now if I wanted to I can disconnect this line and go directly into here like so and it does pretty much the same thing.
So that's super helpful and convenient.
You can also say I'm going to just copy these for a second and do control D. Get them in place and I can also collapse nodes whenever I want to.
So I can right click and say collapse these nodes and then you can actually name them whatever you need.
You can say UV set control and that also is very helpful.
Now just be aware when you do collapse your nodes and you decide you want to send this material to somewhere else like another project.
If you right click and you say hey man I want to go to asset actions and migrate.
These may not stay together.
They may either be unrecognized or they will just unfold themselves and go back to the original state.
So just be aware that sometimes I get that happening.
It does happen a good amount of time when you go into a new version of Unreal.
So just triple check your workflow.
I think it's less of a problem now but previous versions it kind of was a little bit of an issue.
So we have a way to collapse it.
We can do a name reroute.
We can also reroute in general like say I wanted to connect this particular node to another maybe emissive.
Maybe I like my normal route.
There's no way out.
In God's green earth there's no way I would do this but if I wanted to I can double click on any string.
I can move it if my move icon shows up as I float over.
And what this does is it allows me to run another reroute node if I wanted to.
So if I wanted to put this into my emissive it would look horrible.
I can and then you have a glowing normal emissive.
But this allows me to do a simple reroute.
Not a named reroute but a simple one.
And it is a pretty darn good job of being able to do that.
I'm going to undo that for a second.
You can also group your materials which we'll get into later.
That allows me to select a particular material.
And I can go in here and say hey I'm going to choose a group that I wanted to have.
You can type in here under groups in any exposed texture here.
We can actually have that.
Let me show you what I mean.
So I'm going to hit the T key here for a second and left click.
This is the hot key to be able to give me my texture.
If I wanted a UV texture to show up or UV node I should say it for control.
That's the U key and you left click also.
There's also a constant you can pull up.
I keep my finger on the one key.
That's a one constant.
That's a two constant.
And then this is a three.
Simply by me hitting one, two, three and left click.
You keep my finger down on those particular numbers.
Now I did this for the texture sample here.
In this texture sample we'll just get something simple.
We'll just pull up the gray.
Now by himself you'll notice there is no area to group.
But if we go to the other one, this is called a parameter that's been exposed here,
which allows me to not only change its name but also group it.
So to be able to do that you click on any texture, right click, and you say convert to a parameter.
And then we can give it a name.
We'll call this gray texture.
So there's now gray texture allows me to go in here and if I wanted to type in or give it no group,
but type in, I can type in any group right here and it will now create a new group for this particular texture.
Pretty cool.
Now I'm going to go through as we build our material, our parent material, and our instance material.
I'll walk you through some of the hotkeys to build some of these out just as a reminder.
And so you can get a little more familiar with how to work and build things in Unreal.
And that's about it with this video.